we need reinforcements up here hi I'm
Nick Gillespie with reason TV and today
we're talking with Thomas Massie he is
the United States representative for
Kentucky's fourth congressional district
since 2012
congressman Massie thanks for talking to
us thanks Nick what I would like to do
is to you know introduce our viewers to
you
via a couple of recent votes that you
gave and then we'll talk about what kind
of binds us together but you voted
recently for the Keystone XL pipeline
how did you vote and why how did I voted
for it and I voted because I thought
that the government was trying to hold
up the project and then that it you know
it makes total sense then to build that
pipeline and to you know bring Canadian
oil through the country it does to me
and it's going to refineries in our
country I sit on the committee that you
know marked up the bill and so I got a
chance to hear the amendments that the
Democrats offered and they had some good
points but most of their amendments were
designed to kill the bill I wish they
had offered amendments that were
actually constructive one of my concerns
was the eminent domain aspect of it and
so how do you deal with that because a
while ago we made the mistake of saying
you know why not build the pipeline and
people were like oh come on it's all
eminent domain so what do you do well
you know this is where you discover that
our founders weren't libertarians
necessarily at least they were pragmatic
in the sense because eminent domain is
in the Constitution so is intellectual
property and some other things that
perhaps libertarians don't always agree
with but my concern in the Keystone bill
was to make sure that there was still a
path for justice for people whose
property whose property is being taken
yeah and there is let's talk about sis
ba yeah I voted against sis Pathet was
an easy no vote so it stands for the
Cyber Intelligence Sharing and
Protection Act and so what this bill
does is it voids contract law between
customers and their service provider
the service provider can no longer be
held accountable to the customer if they
violate the fundamental rights or even a
contract by sharing their information
with the government now in exchange the
payoff to the businesses the reason the
business world and all their lobbyists
were for this bill is because it
absolves them of any liability
are you worried in general about
government surveillance of everyday
communications and I mean it's clear
that the federal government and probably
governments all over the world have the
ability to basically snag virtually any
communication that's happening do we
need better laws in place to protect
against abuses and and can we protect
against abuses you know my background is
technology I went to MIT and got
engineering degrees and what a lot of
what I see Congress grapple with here is
the introduction of new technology into
society and trying to resolve that with
the existing laws I don't necessarily
think we need new laws we need to
respect the Constitution so just because
we have a new type of technology like
the internet or drones for instance it
doesn't mean that all of our
constitutional rights have to go away we
you know as congressmen we have to be
sure that they're preserved even with
the advent of new technology speaking of
the internet internet sales tax what's
your position on that
I am passionately against the internet
sales tax now there euphemistically
calling it the Marketplace Fairness Act
anything that's got that's kind of like
security and sharing or protection and
sharing rights or the Patriot Act we
know it's the exact top
it's doublespeak it's Orwellian
doublespeak and it's not about fairness
it's about lobbyists coming up here for
big corporations and asking Congress to
help pummel their competition using a
tax I mean you have people arguing it's
not a tax increase is that or they'll
say that this tax is being raised or
it's not being raised this is a tax that
consumers already owed right because I
guess and I mean in the marketplace
essentially what the internet sales tax
will do is it will authorize state and
local governments to get payments from
internet vendors
way that most most of us can avoid that
because if amazon.com or Best Buy
doesn't have a physical presence in a
location then you don't have to pay
sales tax right at the state of Kentucky
who can Pell a vendor in New York to
collect Kentucky sales tax and I'm I'm
saying this is unprecedented it changes
the fabric of our country too it turns
it into the virtual United States the
physical nexus was held to be the
trigger by the Supreme Court for any
kind of regulation or taxation is there
is there an argument to be made though
that taxes should be collected at the
place where the sale is made rather than
where the where the consumer is so let's
say you're in Kentucky you buy something
from a company in New York should you be
taxed at New York's state income tax
rate to receive that in Kentucky now I
contend the states can do that already
the states can tax the transaction they
choose not to tax that transaction
because the companies will leave right
and part of this so-called Marketplace
Fairness Act it's about harmonizing tax
laws so that companies can't and
consumers can't escape one state's taxes
by going to another state and it takes
away the competition that we have among
the states the healthy competition let's
talk a little bit about IRS oversight
because you're on you're on the
committee of the Oversight Committee
that is conducting IRS hearings what is
your take on what's been going on in the
IRS and is are the Republicans and the
Democrats getting this right or are they
missing the bigger picture when they
look at clear
I've been widely admitted abuses of IRS
power well clearly laws were broken and
abuse has happened there at the
Cincinnati office of the IRS and it goes
all the way to Washington but
Republicans and Democrats are missing
the boat here there they've both adopted
or internalized this premise that a
ninety thousand person bureaucracy
that's a hundred years old and in charge
of enforcing 70,000 pages of tax code
could actually operate without
corruption or bias they mean the
hearings I was disappointed in the
hearings I sat through them and I asked
own questions but the Republicans and
the Democrats both seem to agree that if
we just got the right people in the IRS
we could make the IRS work I think we
should be litigating not the
administration and not necessarily the
people who serve in the IRS but the
whole concept of an IRS and the big
government so what what would replace
that then in terms of if you don't want
you know you don't want an income tax or
an IRS what how does the government
collect tax revenue well if you had a
flat tax you could potentially have an
IRS that's one hundredth of the size it
is right now and that would be your
preference a flat tax like a seventeen
percent flat tax or fair tax I the heir
tax which is actually a consumption tax
if you did away with the income tax has
advantages as well either of those would
be preferable to what we have today are
you satisfied that the the problems at
the IRS were contained within the
Cincinnati office or within a few bad
actors and in DC sending them or do we
know what's going on yet we don't know
fully of quote of course Lois Lerner
took the fifth it would be nice if we
could get her to answer to some of the
questions the Commissioner of the other
has a constitutionalist you have to
respect her right I do I respect her
right although you know I still have my
own right to question whether she did
the right things when she was there the
acting commissioner at the time of the
IRS would not accept responsibility I
asked him that was one of my questions
will you accept responsibility he
wouldn't accept responsibility for it
meaning that he did not give the orders
right to look at these groups more
closely that's what he said and he also
said he didn't convey any of these
issues to the white house although the
white house logs showed that he was
there a hundred and eighteen times over
the course of two years so it's hard to
believe their eyes understand they have
an incredible coffee shop at the white
it must be really he said he came for
the Easter Egg Roll
but listen again we're kind of getting
off the top here the problem is it
doesn't matter if it was that gentleman
or Lois Lerner who it's the government
is an organism big government is a
organism that Congress has created and
it's it's its own defense mechanism
kicking in it's conceivable that people
somewhere below the White House just
decided on their own to attack small
government organizations this is big
government going after small government
proponents that's just a natural
tendency of this monster that we've
created and you're arguing that it you
know just at an organization that site
all kinds of weird stuff is going to
happen despite the best intentions I
mean we can't always rely on the best
intention so describe your governing
philosophy I mean what's the role of
government in Thomas Massey's worldview
well I can't articulate it any better
than Basquiat did into law but that's by
description what the role of government
is what what one person how one person
treats another person doesn't change
when you've got a thousand people voting
for one person who then treats those
thousand people the same basic
principles apply but okay so
fundamentally what should government be
doing and this goes to why I wanted to
be on the transportation committee my
only experience in government prior
prior to coming to Congress was as a
County Executive and basically an
administrator of the most granular local
form of government you can imagine and
it's sort of a libertarian hell because
you have to provide all of these basic
functions of government but you know and
we can argue about whether we should
build another library and I would argue
we probably shouldn't they're outdated
and it's it's not a function that
government needs to provide but very few
people argue about the roads or the
police protection that happens at the
local level and as well as national
defense yeah so that scales from at the
local level I found out even your most
avid tea partiers wanted the roads paved
and wanted the police to show up when
something happened the same thing at the
state level and here at the federal
level that applies to national defense
and a transportation infrastructure
where there is a federal Nexus so when I
came to Congress it's on
voidable we're spending money here we're
spending way more than our spendin three
point six trillion dollars you know this
year what what should we be spending
next year we shouldn't spend any more
than we bring in which is really three
trillion yeah our deficit was about
trillion last year thanks to the fiscal
cliff deal or no thanks to the fiscal
cliff which you voted against and you
voted against for a particular reason
what was it well there were several
reasons I vote against the fiscal cliff
deal not only did it raise taxes on to
the tax brackets it raised also the
social security tax but it also extended
spending it expanded spending on for
instance unemployment insurance and it
perpetuated some of the inequities in
the tax code like green tax credits it
was just a I call it a really big turd
sandwich without the bread well you know
everybody nobody wants carbs anymore so
I guess it's a paleo this is paleo
governor yeah you know the government
should be doing very few functions
essentially and they're ones that where
there's a clear kind of consensus that
these things should be done what are the
things in the at the federal level that
can be cut I mean you know there are the
big issues and the drivers of debt like
defense spending Social Security
Medicare but then there are other things
like fit the federal role in education
you would want to see that completely
destroyed eliminated Department of
Education Department of Energy we don't
need either of the do E's and what would
happen I mean spin out of fantasy or an
imagined world of like how would that
make education better in America because
you know Republicans Ronald the
Department of Education is not
particularly old it was you know created
by Jimmy Carter and it was Ronald Reagan
said he was going to can it and didn't
he expanded it vastly so Republicans and
Democrats you know have problem you know
they're part of the problem here how
would education get better if we got rid
of the federal Department of Education
well it it's in order to answer that I
have to tell you how it's been worse
because of the federal Department of
Education the federal Department of
Education in
exchange for some of the money that they
dole out his required standards or
standardization and compliance with
rules at the federal government level
and I don't think our country is a
one-size-fits-all country and you know
we have 50 different states that are all
petri dishes for experiments in
education and we'd have more competition
and less of a homogeneous education
being promulgated by the government so
take take that out of the equation you
have more competition and more
flexibility and just less bureaucracy
the money doesn't multiply when it goes
from the states to the federal
government back to the state you know
youyou talk a lot I mean in terms of tax
competition in terms of petri dishes you
know the idea of the states as
laboratories of democracy in terms of
gay marriage you are not you you don't
think that should be a federal issue
marriage but are you are against the
idea that states would have to recognize
marriage equality is that correct I
don't think a state in like the state of
Kentucky should have to be forced to
recognize marriage arrangements in the
state of Massachusetts if Massachusetts
decides to do this I don't think the
state of Kentucky should be forced
advice first so that's consistent
actually with the idea of having a
decentralized approach to governance I
think so and the federal government
really should be out of more you know it
should be in very few things because
there are very few things that have to
be dictated at the federal level and I
don't I don't think the federal
government should be involved in
marriage at all and to the extent that
they are through benefits or taxation if
we had the right tax code it wouldn't
matter now in terms of let's talk about
marijuana legalization because you you
are in favor of an industrial hemp
legislation you've supported it for the
state of Kentucky as well as a national
bill but you're against pot legalization
for recreational use is it okay that I
mean what should happen to states like
Colorado and Washington that have
legalized pot you know through
plebiscite should the federal government
step down
and allow them to experiment or should
they enforce federal laws that would put
people in jail for growing selling and
using pop I think the federal government
should respect the state's rulings on
these things and in fact you know I
wouldn't my constituents in Kentucky are
not for legalization of marijuana and I
don't expect that the state of Kentucky
would legalize it although it's a big
pot growing state right by all accounts
not that you would know I don't know
what happens there we we grew tobacco on
my farm okay but no you know the bill
that I've sponsored here in the house HR
525 it was a Ron Paul bill in the last
Congress would legalize industrial hemp
and it's very simple bill it's a
one-pager it just takes industrial hemp
off of the list of controlled substances
what is the opposition to that because
you know you don't have to be a kind of
hippie you know wearing Wallabies and a
poncho to understand that industrial
hemp is a totally different beast than
it has a you know an endless number of
uses and a long and storied history
going that in the colonies and including
George Washington growing it what what's
the opposition to an industrial and it
was grown in Kentucky up until about
fifty years ago in large numbers so
fifty or sixty years ago the opposition
I think is the lack of education about
industrial hemp when you tell people
it's grown in Canada it's grown in
Europe it's grown in every industrial
country in the world except the United
States their ears perk up and then when
you tell them that we import it and you
can go buy products in you know in the
store right now and the supermarket's
and lows that are made with this stuff
and we can't grow it here they get more
interested and you know it's for me it's
more opportunity for farmers in Kentucky
it's an easy bill to sponsor for myself
it's just an educational campaign and I
think Ron Paul had 36 co-sponsors in the
last Congress 10 of those didn't return
so I had started out with 26 I've got 14
new co-sponsors I'm up to 40 co-sponsors
of the bill and it's just a slow
you know educational campaign talk about
Medicare and Social Security I mean
these are you know old-age entitlements
which are generally popular and
certainly among the people who benefit
from them and they're problematic you
know they are you know taking up huge
amounts of money they're unsustainable
in their current form what is you know
what's your preferred option to replace
them and then short of that how do we
reform them in a way that doesn't kind
of throw people under the bus but also
it doesn't bankrupt you know the next
ten generations of Americans
well the Social Security is not the
open-ended promise that Medicare is so
you could actually fix Social Security
if you had a few brave souls here to
tweak things just a little bit you could
fix Social Security it's a promise to
give people money in exchange for the
money they've been giving to the
government it's there is no trust fund
up here there's no lockbox I've looked
around the law and I can't find anything
buried up here in fact it was started
that way it's a transfer payment that's
still what it is but you could you could
still make that work
conceivably would you want it to keep
working or would you rather it be you
know a kind of minimum income for for
seniors say or for poor people well for
all the people that have that are
relying on the program I think you have
to keep the commitment but I'd like to
see some way for the younger generation
let's say 40 and under to invest in
other things for the retirement now
Medicare is a bigger problem because
it's it isn't Medicare's open-eyed
Medicare is an open-ended promise to
provide health care it's not a dollar
amount it's there's no limit to the
promise and as technologies come into
play you know now you can have a hip
replacement or stents put in or
transplants for instance as all these
new procedures come online the question
is what are you entitled to in exchange
for the money you've paid into Medicare
which covers at most I mean when you
look at personal contributions plus
co-pays and things it's less than 50
percent
right of the how the payment per
beneficiary well and if you look at what
the beneficiaries have paid into it a
couple when by the time they go on to
Medicare is paid in about 110,000 and
they can expect to receive 300,000 of
benefits that part of its just not so
what how do we how do we fix that I
think Paul Ryan was on the right track
you have to introduce some free market
forces
unfortunately that gets demagogued this
issue is very volatile and people will
come in and you know you know the
commercials you've seen you know but you
have to introduce some kind of market
forces back into it do do you also need
to means-test in a more serious way I
mean should should seniors simply or
should people simply by dint of turning
65 you know get an open-ended
entitlement or even one that's
constrained by market forces well when
you talk about this things yeah you
could go ahead and means-test it I mean
it's people need to be disabused of the
notion that the like Social Security is
a compulsory individual retirement
account that you've paid in some money
and that the money you get back is
directly proportional to it it is not in
fact Social Security's are ready
progressively taxed so it's in a sense
it's sort of means-tested as the money
goes in you can do more of that with
Social Security with Medicare if you
wanted one thing you don't benefit from
much in Medicare that you do in Social
Security and Social Security if you
raise the age a couple years you save
that much money but in Medicare when you
raise the age a couple of years you
really don't save much money because
most of the health care dollars are
provided toward the end of life
generally speaking across-the-board you
want the government to be spending less
money you know certainly no more of them
were taken in and you'd prefer to take
in less than we take in but you're also
generally pro-defense
talk about you know are we spending the
right amount of money on defense are we
spending too much are we spending too
little I don't think we need to spend
any more on defense than we are right
now it's almost twice of what we were
spending ten or twelve years ago and we
were fine ten or twelve years ago you
know the question
is what's the right amount to spend on
defense and it and it depends on how
many engagements you're involved in
certainly you don't want to get into a
war or some kind of engagement and then
underfund it because then you're just
putting lives unnecessarily at risk but
I would argue we should be less engaged
in things overseas you mentioned earlier
you're an MIT grad you're an engineer by
training how does engineering fit into
your worldview and you know it's
interesting you define yourself as a
libertarian I would say you could use
any of these terms constitutional
conservative or libertarian leaning
Republican and people like Friedrich
Hayek you know the libertarian economist
he he had a thing against what he called
the engineering mentality you know that
and for him engineers were these people
who could plan fast you know complicated
scenarios and tweak knobs and make
everything work why are you you know you
you don't have the engineering mentality
that he was talking about although you
were trained as an engineer how does
being an engineer help you think about
politics well there aren't many
engineers in Congress I'll tell you
right off the bat a lot of politicians
get here by dint of intuition and
feelings and ability to communicate
which is good you need all of those
things but engineers rely on facts I
mean we for instance
remember John Sununu came senior came to
MIT and gave a speech and I don't
remember anything about the speech other
than this he said we need more engineers
in Congress and fewer lawyers because
engineers are trained to collect facts
and come up with a premise based on
those facts lawyers are trained to take
a premise and go collect the facts to
make that to prove that premise
regardless of whether the premise was
true or not so it's like the scientific
method and I don't see it applied very
often here in Congress well and that I
might
you had as a macro in a macroeconomic
lesha at a professor named Paul Krugman
this was back in 1991 what do you
remember from Krugman's class well thank
goodness I took a microeconomics class
before I took his macroeconomics class
or I might have been scared away from
economics forever
I loved my micro class you could explain
human behavior coupons why there's a
first-class ticket and a coach ticket on
the same airplane why they cost
different amounts of money why free
trade is good if this island has chips
and this island has salsa that both
islands are going to be happier when
they start trading so micro economics I
was it was like opening a new world to
me explaining human behavior with math
then when I took professor Craig Mullins
course it was more of a religion and we
were being asked to believe this and he
would say well we believe this here but
in Chicago they believe this and I
thought I didn't come to MIT to adopt
somebody's belief system I came here to
use math to explain things and I learned
from it that there's a lot of witchcraft
involved in macroeconomics particularly
the Keynesian view of the world you were
a business owner talk a little bit about
your entrepreneurial streak and how that
informs your governing philosophy so
when I was at MIT I invented a few
things started a company started it as a
subchapter S corporation tried to
navigate the tax code right off the bat
and learned very early on that
government wasn't necessarily there to
help you it was this thing you had to
navigate in order to start your business
or to keep your business going learned
an appreciation for free trade again
because 60% of what we manufactured and
so what were your manufacturer so I
invented a three-dimensional touch
interface with my device an artist or a
doctor could sit down and touch
three-dimensional objects inside of the
computer and then for the in the case of
the doctor he could do a surgical
simulation and learn a procedure without
operating on a
and feel what the procedure felt like in
the case of the artists they could
sculpt you know another toy or shoes or
jewelry or a car dashboard and feel it
while you was sculpting it and it was
very novel type stuff and we you know it
goes straight to the 3d printer yeah why
are you wasting your time in Congress
you're wasting everybody's talking about
you gotta follow up and there's 3d
printers I mean these you know with the
printing of a gun you know my god
everybody is terrified do you see that
as the next great leap forward in terms
of human ingenuity and innovation
I see 3d printing as the democratization
of creation kind of like the internet
read amah critized commerce you know you
can go on eBay and sell something you
can start a company so easily and find a
ready-made market with this sort of
democratizes the manufacturing process
and it makes it possible for you to
design your own personal version of what
you want and and have it printed out
immediately I'm excited I you know when
I was in business it was the early 90s
in the into 2000 the great thing about
patents and I know some libertarians are
against patents but the great thing
about patents is they do spur innovation
and they spurred innovation in the 90s
the but the good thing about patents is
they expire and back in the 90s I was
thinking I can't wait until 17 years
from now when all these 3d printer
patents expire there's going to be a
revolution because we're gonna have
consumer 3d printers and that's what
you're starting to see right now those
patents those seminal patents are
expiring and but those patents are
important for because if people are
developing the stuff can't monopolize
they the profit stream or the revenue
stream for a while they won't bother
right and it's in it's in the
Constitution this is another example
where it said that the founding fathers
may not have been libertarians because
they put intellectual property in there
as pragmatic concession the they already
knew that it would spur innovation but
the great thing about this country is
the deal was if you create it you get to
keep it not your boss not the government
you get to keep that
for a period of time but when it comes
to copyright though you are not I mean I
can't imagine that you're in favor of an
open-ended copyright system which seems
to be what we have that every time
Mickey Mouse or some other you know very
influential icon or property of a
company comes ready to go into the
public domain suddenly it's 75 years
it's 90 years it's a hundred years that
the copyright stays in force for so
Justin Amash and I we're talking about
this very example on the floor of the
house today and really I think that's
cronyism that's not what the founding
fathers intended when the copyright
expires it should expire it shouldn't be
re extended because you have lobbyists
here in Washington DC and you've got
some kind of Empire to protect the
founding fathers stated in the
Constitution for limited periods of time
for a reason because that's the only
real way that you spurred creation and
innovation now there are some issues of
other issues of copyright and patents
that have been abused much to the
detriment of American consumers and one
of the bills that I've recently
introduced with so Lofgren as a
co-sponsor from Silicon Valley is one
that will fix part of the DMCA that the
Digital Millennium Copyright Act which
is problematic across the board
yeah well part of that bill when they
passed it makes it a crime for you to
unlock your cellphone regardless of
whether you have a contract with the
carrier it's still a crime to unlock
your cellphone and we're trying to fix
that because I believe if you purchase a
copy of something you own that copy
whether it's a piece of hardware whether
it's a song you can change the music if
you want you should be able to rewire
the hardware if you want but that copy
is yours and that's fundamental property
right and I'm glad to see that Democrats
agree with me on that do you think
there's a generational shift I mean you
as you are an insurgent within the
Republican Party
you you crossed kind of sorts with John
Boehner early on in your tenure you work
a lot with people like Justin Amash and
Rand Paul is there a generational shift
going on that is also dispositional I
mean you're much more libertarian than
the typical Republican you're also more
tech savvy you're more embedded in the
world as it's happening as opposed to
you know maybe somebody like John McCain
you know I mean is this is are there
gonna be more of you regardless of what
happens or you know how do you duplicate
yourself we need reinforcements up here
now the good news that I got when I came
to Congress is it's not just Justin
Amash and me there at least half a dozen
possibly a dozen depending on where you
draw the line of libertarian leaning
constitutional conservatives in Congress
we need more the other bit of good news
is that if you look at a vote like
sistah the Cyber Intelligence Sharing
and Protection Act you were two or three
times more likely to vote against sis
but if you just got to Congress this
cycle then if you'd been here for more
than a congressional what do you think
explains that it's the generational
shift that you asked about I mean some
of these folks are younger they
understand we the dangers of letting the
government read your email run and
they're more in tune with their
constituents who are you know of the
same talk a little bit about what turns
you on to politics you know what were
the events and the kind of trigger
points for them because you you were a
county executive before you came to
Congress but you're not a you you didn't
wake up at age 10 and say wow I want to
be Congress or anything like that what
what brought you here now it was age 40
before I decided I wanted anything to do
with this place
you know I always paid attention to what
was going on in the world even though I
had a company to run and in patents to
develop and whatnot but what I remember
at MIT in 1993 when I was writing my
undergraduate thesis Waco happened
the event there in Texas and it became
obvious to me that maybe the government
wasn't there to help those people when
the narrative was their children being
abused and we're going to go in and help
those children and they brought tanks
and and guns and helicopters and started
poking holes in the wall and firing CS
gas I'm like maybe our government is a
little too big and so that was 20 years
ago
and I remember watching that that
concerned me enough that I watched the
hearings on c-span and I remember
watching a congressman like Sonny Bono
cry in the hearings there were a few
that fully grasped what went on there
and so I don't think you have to be a
conspiracy theorist to realize that the
government is sometimes out of control
just look at the facts that are in front
of you so that shaped part of my concern
over big government and the infringement
on our civil liberties the other was you
know my experience in business in paying
taxes I guess as a job creator and well
and you've said that working against an
Occupational tax is kind of what helped
you get into Kentucky politics yeah
there were before there was the Tea
Party this was in 2006 or 2007 I had
sold my ownership in my company in New
England come back to Kentucky to raise
my family on a farm and you live in a
house that you built you're off the grid
it's solar powered by my house is solar
powered I tell Republicans you can hate
the subsidies I hate the subsidies too
but you can't hate solar panels these
are rocks that make electricity so
they're incapable of receiving your hate
there there are good things now we
shouldn't be subsidizing them but yes my
house off the grid I built it with wood
from my own farm I built my own ponds I
wanted to experience as much freedom as
I could so to speak and you could find
that there in Kentucky where I grew up
what I experienced as a kid but what I
realized was that our county government
was starting to catch the same disease
as the federal government and they were
becoming more intrusive under Bush they
were going to consolidate these
conservation offices Kentucky has 120
counties they had 120 conservation
offices well our county got nervous and
decided our county government said we
need to make sure that consolidation
happens here we want the federal
government in our County let's pass a
new tax and build a brick building a
field of dreams for government you know
so they wanted to build on the idea that
the federal government would come to
occupy this building paid for with the
new tax yeah and I thought it was a
really bad idea so I wrote a letter to
the editor if I had taken that letter to
the editor and thrown it in the trash I
would not be here in Congress today I
assure you but instead I took it to the
newspaper and I published it and we had
150 people show up at a meeting where
nobody ever showed up before we stopped
this new tax and it was it was just
almost like a scene from a movie that
day when we had a hundred and fifty
people show up and stop this tax but I
got progressively more involved there
was a zoning effort to zone all the
agricultural land in our County which is
like 99 percent of our land which to me
is a taking when somebody has the option
of building a business on their farm and
you take that option away you've taken
something from them so I opposed that
opposed a library tax and a few other
things and then decided it was probably
easier just to run for office and I was
kind of the dog that chased the bus but
one day I caught the bus and I was then
holding the key to the courthouse and it
felt like breaking and entering the day
that you know the first day of work is
the county executive but when I got in
there I found waste everywhere every
bill that we pay that our county
government paid had waste on it the
phone bills were paying for phone lines
that weren't hooked up we were paying
for electric meters that didn't even
belong to the county just everywhere you
looked every Rock you turned over was
and you were popular and successful in
cutting cutting government ways well
when I found the waste I wanted
everybody in the other counties to know
there was probably money being wasted
there so I would go and speak in these
other counties the Tea Party groups or
912 groups or whoever wanted to listen
to me and that's when I developed sort
of a small following there of people who
understood that you could make a
difference at the local level you didn't
have to be in state politics or in
federal politics you you are a big
favorite of the tea party you're one of
the you know kind of the valedictorian
almost of the the most recent class of
tea party candidates to win do you think
the tea party strays from its most
effective message when it gets off of
the idea that we're spending too much
and a lot of Tea Party groups are kind
of seem very hostile to immigration or
they seem much more fixated on securing
the border than reducing spending how do
you think that plays out and how does it
inform your views on immigration you
know when I watched the Republican
revolution in the 90s which was kind of
the first wave of the Tea Party but they
didn't have the name then I tried to
figure out who was for smaller
government and who was for bigger
government I didn't care what the labels
were Democrat Republican liberal
conservative were you for smaller
government or bigger government and I
think the Tea Party should stick to that
in my race it was kind of the coalition
of three groups as I saw them the Ron
Paul Liberty folks the Tea Party folks
and just Ronald Reagan conservatives who
would have been part of the conservative
revolution in the 90s just Republicans
who don't ascribe to any labels but are
for smaller government they know we're
spending too much I wish we would stick
to that because when we separate on on
social issues we trust me we don't have
the numbers here in Congress to pass the
fiscal issue so what is immigration is
you know front and center you know what
do we need do we have an immigration
problem and if we do what what should we
be addressing first well I think borders
are important and I think we should
secure our border I think we should take
away the welfare incentive to come here
most immigrants come here to work in
Kentucky they the legal
temporary workers work on farms and
provide important service in Kentucky
otherwise our food is probably going to
come from China because we can't compete
with that should we have more temporary
visas for agricultural workers or look
what what it's considered low-skilled
immigrants would that help too I mean if
the problem is illegal immigration do we
need to have more avenues for legal
immigration I think we do that's what
the farmers in Kentucky tell me there
are some that comply with the law and
some that break the law and I've not
spoke with the ones that break the law
but when I speak to the ones that comply
with the law they say you know when I
try to do this legally I open up my farm
to three government agencies that can
come here at any hour any time any day
and write me up on violations do you
think if we expand the possible pool of
legal immigration we actually help to
secure the border because then more
people will be streaming through
authorized checkpoints I think we will I
think we do need a more streamlined
worker visa program not just for farm
workers by the way we're going to be
left in the dust on stem issues this
stands for science technology
engineering and math we let the students
come here to be and we train them but
then we sort of kick them back out of
the country and these are some of your
most entrepreneurial individuals that
have ever crossed our borders we would
be we would do well to keep them here
you're a man of faith could you talk a
little bit about your faith and how that
informs your sense of government or or
your limits to government why government
maybe shouldn't be calling most of the
shots at anybody's life I keep my
personal views or try to on religion
separate from my public life here in
Congress it's important to me my faith
is important to me I'll be home this
Sunday with my family in church and I
think it's it's helpful in guiding my
personal life but I don't want to impose
those views on anybody else here so in a
way that's also I mean
kind of Laboratory of you know a
laboratory of democracy of experiment
understanding that things that are
personal and central to people's value
systems should be even people should be
able to experiment as much as they want
as long as they're not forcing other
people into certain behaviors I think we
should respect other people's religions
other people's views of the world and
try not to impose our own on them I mean
and this is this is what government is
about government is not about protecting
us from ourselves
government fundamentally is about
providing some of these services you
can't provide in the private sector but
also just protecting people from
infringing on other people's rights or
views just a final comment you've been
you know you've been in office now for a
few months are you optimistic that your
children will inherit a you know in
America that is more free and more
prosperous than the one that you
inherited as you know or when you showed
up here I mean are you fearful of the
future are you optimistic that we will
we will do well I am I am an optimist at
heart so I am optimistic that our
country is going to go forward but I
don't think it's going to be because of
anything we do here in Congress I think
that private industry and private
individuals will succeed in spite of
Congress's inability to get out of their
way sometimes but I'm also an optimist
that we can make a change here that we
can have a difference that's why I came
here and I'm ready to stick it out and
fight the fight
well we'll leave it at that thank you
very much representative Thomas Massie
of the Kentucky's fourth congressional
district thank you very much thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]